well day thirteen of the partial
government shutdown begins an era of
divided government of Democrats seeking
control of the House of Representatives
president dropping congressional leaders
refused to budge on their demands to end
the shutdown during a closed-door
meeting in the White House Situation
Room yesterday Democrats won't pay for a
border wall but are offering to spend
1.3 billion dollars for general border
security mr. Trump insists on 5.6
billion dollars to help build a wall
House Speaker designee Nancy Pelosi
plans a vote on two measures today to
reopen the government Senate Republican
leader Mitch McConnell says the Senate
will only vote on a plan that the
president would sign mr. Trump offered
to continue the negotiations tomorrow it
can be hard to imagine a time when the
two parties might have agreed to build a
wall along the Mexican border but
starting in 2006 the federal government
has built nearly 700 miles of wall and
fencing with bipartisan support we asked
Tony to copal to sort out when and how
the physical border barrier created a
political one Tony good morning good
morning president Trump and his allies
have accused Democrats of flip-flopping
on border security voting in favor of a
barrier in 2006 but now refusing one
Democratic leaders Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer for their part say in
effect not all barriers are created
equal and mr. Trump's big beautiful wall
idea would in fact be expensive and
ineffective at more than 10 feet tall
and made of steel barriers like these
might seem like a prototype of president
Trump's border wall in fact there is
sampling of what's already in place
along the us-mexico border in more
remote areas you'll find shorter vehicle
barriers like these all part of the
secure Fence Act a 2006 political
compromise on immigration signed by
President Bush and supported by ninety
Democratic members of Congress it
included funding for two layers of
reinforced fencing plus additional
physical barriers along roughly 700
miles of border from California to Texas
among the senators who backed it Barack
Obama Hillary Clinton and current
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer the fence
is now basically complete a 2007
Republican amendment gave the Department
of
homeland security control over where to
build the barriers and since much of the
rest of the border is protected by
natural barriers like rivers America's
great border controversy was over I will
build the greatest wall that you've ever
seen or so it seemed who's gonna pay for
the wall president Trump's comments on
the lane we need really a thousand miles
height and design of his wall have
varied widely since 2015 so widely
there's no telling what he'll accept in
the end it gets higher and higher and
higher every time somebody says I'm not
gonna bid for it and so the standoff and
the shutdown continues in his 2017
executive order authorizing a border
wall President Trump
officially defined the wall as a quote
impassable physical barrier from the
president's perspective at the moment
that definition might also describe the
New Democratic Congress Nora alright
Tony thank you you know the Washington
Post has a really great piece today that
this budget shutdown is already putting
a huge strain on the u.s. immigration
system the men and women who actually
guard our border they're not being paid
the companies that are trying to use the
e-verify system to check and see if the
person they're going to hire is actually
an American citizen or has a green card
that system is down at this hour the
courts in order the process that's down
this is creating a whole other problem
in addition to the fact that those who
want border security this is hurting the
system and we've got to wake up to that
they've gotta find a deal and the
president is hoping that the Democrats
will cave pointing to what they did in
2006 important to remember this is a
very different Democratic Party and the
mounting stress for all these families
who don't know when they're gonna get a
paycheck at this point
thank you again Tony great reporting